[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la semaine dernière c'est fabien
lecoeuvre
c était le champion avec sa vidéo du
moonwalk avec donc le cousin de fabien
lecoeuvre qui faisait un moonwalk
c'est qui lui voilà qui est gagné la
semaine année on va revoir le gagnant de
la semaine dernière donc fabien
lecoeuvre garde donc ça c'était le
champion de la semaine dernière va
détrôner fabien lecoeuvre avec sa vidéo
de la semaine et c'est pascal qui va
juger bien entendu puisque c'est pascal
le patron ce soir ludivine on va
démarrer par vous j ai remarqué sur ma
fiche magnéto new york ray c'est ça
exactement je l'avais on est en période
de grève en ce moment bien sûr donc il
ya des petits fraudeurs il ya des petits
génies
j'ai trouvé le meilleur d'entre tous
médias pas des gravats new york mais
c'est pas grave on transpose aussi
réussi à coller ensuite actu coupé
décalé qui devrait vous plaire regard et
a coupé décalé qui deux fois qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle
[Applaudissements]
madore layton
ben ouais c'est pas bien mais surtout
prendre le métro à l'arrêt des rues
voire la vidéo mais il a défait sainte
hermine a alors vous mettez la barre
bien haut
notre qu'est ce que vous avez à nos
proches moi j'ai une vidéo j'ai pleuré
de rire mais vraiment c'est un mec qui
se fait chauffer par les flics dans un
supermarché et il cherche une niche
cherche une excuse mais il la trouve
jamais regardé way bâtiment exceptionnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas mal
pascal sait pour l'instant c'est
ludivine qui est championne bah oui
c'est surprenant c'est bon si ça arrive
et ça ça me fait envie
c'est vrai que les deux fautes à côté
audio oui alors ça va être dur de battre
ludivine mais elle est très drôle et
elle est surtout très mignonne elle va
vous plaire cette institutrice
en fait elle n'est pas le mot google et
sans le vouloir a fait un hommage à
pascal légitimus et le célèbre sketch de
télé magouilles regarder pourquoi aulas
et ça c'est bien lancé mehdi c'est
propre c'est français nickel on se dit
oh oh oh bien elle était si boudreau
[Applaudissements]
quoi de voir sa part champions prendra
ce cas là et mais pour l'instant c'est
un match à gagner par magloire relever
le défi ça va être difficile mais on
aime beaucoup
un gendarme un journaliste et ce
gendarme
il a pris un peu la grosse tête il va
tomber de son piédestal
regardez plutôt pas mal pas mal c'est
beaucoup il faut à peu près 400 mètres
d'ici
en attendent que je leur envoie de
vitesse
[Applaudissements]
allez bonne foi que soient les bonnes
mais pascal c'est pas mal mais tu es les
bonnes mais je pense que tout le big
stack choisir à ma place et qu'un
collectif à libre vous pouvez voter sur
twitter voilà la vidéo vous avez préféré
cette fois utile et bien écoutez quand
ça veut pas ça veut pas ça pourrait être
le titre de cette vidéo ça nous est
arrivé à tous n'est peut-être pas autant
regarder voilà et la salle du tissu de
noël on voit là là on est en guerre on
voit clara a fait des bêtises
elle essaie pas à les gags à gogo
on y va
à aux yeux bleus
[Applaudissements]
si fanni pour l'instant rilos en battant
des lames et on dirait qu'elle fait
exprès c'est ça qui est bizarre c'est
que non alors yann lorence
alors attention parce que moi ce que je
vous propose est dans le champion d'arts
cas c'est de la balle et laurence on
dirait vraiment eu ses comptes avec des
copains il à t'attendre qu'arrive à la
maison et dans ta chambre a tellement ta
chambre avec le sens interdit et y'a que
tu attendes qui rentre dans la mer tout
[Musique]
est à une race rameau faire regarder
quoi c'est jabba ça fait 10 le double de
ce qu'on leur doit tu vas comprendre
regardez a essayé de la balle
[Applaudissements]
calvet lannoy j'ai vu une main sauver
une main alors pardon valoir pascal je
pense qu'on est tous d'accord pour dire
que tiffany a gagné 10
[Musique]